[Music]
you worked with one of your all-time
heroes Liam Neeson on the gray and
that's someone everyone must look up to
but he was a big hero of yours big hear
of mine always have just one of my
acting heroes in fact when my wife I
tell the story when my might my wife was
pregnant we went to see him on Broadway
I do the crucible she was pregnant we
wound up naming our middle kid Liam oh
wow and years later I was working with
him and so he's big Liam and we have
little Liam and you know he's kind of
like become this action hero since he's
I guess 60 years old and since he did
taken yeah and I recently you know I've
started to get into this genre and I
called him I said buddy give me some
advice give me cuz you know it talks
like this a Frankie
you know and he's bleep nice you oh man
bigger than you I think yeah let's not
get crazy
look I don't mean just give me some
advice you know I'm old you're old like
I'm going again and he goes Frankie if I
could give you one piece of advice mate
I said yes Liam like us on my knees I
like yes Liam give me the advice he goes
keep your knees healthy mate what does
that mean keep your knees healthy that
was the sage advice I got the wings
what's that that's that's what I mean
eat so I changed my kid's name to Bart
that's crappy advice right yeah
you